I was told that you had a back injury
recently and I was worried about you you
seem fine wait thank you thank you very
much um yeah I have a gun l4 l5
situation and l4 l5 yeah that's a
situation yeah injection you've had the
injection the shot the cortisone into
the spine no I've never had a baby
that's every day and it's it's I mean
they go in there and you brought us you
brought in an x-ray is that right or an
MRI MRI oh my god that's serious so so
what's going on here what is the needle
here well that's going directly into my
vertebrae and the nerve and then they
just inject it with cortisone and all
this other stuff see they feel it and
apparently so my doctor is looking at
this and you know and he says well
you're a problem you can take it down
now and I think we've seen enough yeah
we're not doctors
yeah so so it brings the swelling down
here breaks us why daddy looks at me as
he says egos were your problem because I
don't see a butt well in Irish when I'm
really like that's what you're looking
at that and that's all you see is that I
have no butt and that's because I'm not
getting this the doctor said the problem
they are back is that you have no but
have no but I used to but after like
three children in life it just went so I
don't have one anymore and now I have
this back injury and I said I go you're
looking at my spine I mean my butt's not
like that's what you see anything it's
everything goes well it's what I don't
see that guy's a jerk I don't like the
waist I don't like the way that guy's
talking sorry it's wonderful and
literally he's he's in his 80s and I'm
sure everyone has a crush on him that
meets him you would love him oh no
that's like how does it how does him not
having a I mean how does you not having
a butt affect your back apparently like
the muscles and I don't have any there
anymore apparently they've just
deteriorated in in my life
and so I quit trying I don't work out on
that area anymore it's just and a
girlfriend of mine came up with a really
great saying I think you're gonna I'm
not you in particular but just anyone
will love it if you can't tone it tan it
if you can't tone it tan it which means
if you don't have a butt if you can't
get it like a good the oxide makers you
know picking up no are you saying just
tan the butt so well I mean if you
happen to be a person that does not have
a good but then if you tan it it I think
looks better because it's everything
looks good but wait do you tan
everything are you just tan the but
whatever you are that's just weird cuz
then you're walking around and it looks
you're naked but it looks like you're
wearing a brand's well how many people
are gonna do that by the way I've seen
you naked my friend that's all I'm
saying
no we live together that's true you have
seen me man you are grown and you live
to see live to tell the tale
anyway you're laughing I am a good body
what no I listen and I panicked
well wait a minute first of all I didn't
know that guys have to have a but I have
no body
oh yeah they do do they really helps
listen you and I have had a mutual
attraction for a long time yes this
thing a guy has to have a toned but I
didn't know that a guy had okay I mean I
don't know to be tone but it should be
nice round mine there's nothing there's
literally nothing there that's how it is
it's like if you drew you could you
could draw a car a carpenter's plumb
line would go straight down tantek oh
there's actually it actually goes in a
little bit in the Sun get in the Sun
Hannah that's weird I can't even do that
so there's actually nothing I can do I
cannot can it I can't get a butt and I
cannot Tanna but you're married it's
okay she knows yes yeah she weeps she
weeps every night every night my wife
goes to the window and looks out at the
ocean in a single tear yeah yeah you
seem to be enjoying this yeah so
everything good your your your your
Rizzoli and Isles season 6 season 6 are
you Rizzoli or Isles I'm Rizzoli okay
big fan of the show drive around
wondering which ones which I'm resolved
you're resolving fantastic yes
I'm the man you're the man yes I want to
watch the show now
cuz I have to come out here like this so
I can reassure people that I'm actually
female I didn't think that was an issue
I swear to gosh she's reassured me yeah
you're happy
any what you up to I just sitting here
listening to you guys
dai hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please